[Music]
[Applause]
why I don't know I had a small stroke
and I got over it
I can't believe these students selling I
can't believe it that somebody's looking
really good look at this one it's called
senator Mitch McConnell doing turtle
stuff eatin areas he's I think he's
laying eggs and then down here look at
that means just he's making a vote in
the Senate it's late
Hey Hey look at this some fish who would
like a quick word with you I think you
might have scratched my car look at this
guy just wants a quick word there you go
liver this one poorly placed pools look
at that poorly that is a place place
pool yeah not a good place for pool look
at this one right here that's just not a
good that's crazy
it can't have one on the side of a
building Hey look at this one I can't
believe it didn't work
this didn't sell is that Oliver Platt
from behind it's a whole book I'm just
just photograph guys that might be
Oliver bad yeah
very and maybe him
to get my suit he likes nuki and then
look could be and we have no idea way to
know you never find out that's the
beauty of the book Hey look at this you
might want to rethink those knuckle
tattoos look at that this one ring
ringworm
ringworm right there these are not good
not hot look at that one Louie I not
inspire fear the guy watch that for me
look at this I can't believe Wolf
Blitzer would do this I can't believe it
wolf Blitzer's Holland but we are he's
obsessed with butts yeah well don't ask
man well-known ass man there it is it's
just Wolf Blitzer showing us some of his
favorite bucks baby likes he likes that
one and then finally the big book of
animals licking themselves it's all yeah
oh no like you don't own this one this
was this was the only one that sold out
yeah and then you got up there
and then down here check it out it's
just
[Applause]
you